at our Southern border we don't have a
border and all these people are
wandering their asses in to the country
uh Greg Abbott the governor of Texas
he's basically had it with Biden and
Texas is going to build its own wall on
top of all that Texas
is the only state in the history of the
United States of America that it has
ever built its own border wall
we have been in the process over the
past year of acquiring rights on land
owned by private landowners that will
allow us to accelerate the process of
building the border wall over this
coming year there's a possibility uh
depending upon how the construction
process works where by the end of this
calendar year
Texas is a state may have added more
border wall than the Trump
Administration did for the United States
of America during his four years in
office you really need to understand
this this is extraordinary stuff the
states are not supposed to worry about
the national borders they can always pay
a little more attention right if you're
a border state you got to pay a little
more attention say if you're Texas than
if you're just somewhere in the middle
of the country right like that's just
obvious because it's your land right
there but it's not their job it is one
of the few duties of the federal
government to make sure that our borders
as a nation are protected because Biden
and this Administration and mayorkas and
the rest of these people are are
completely not doing their job they're
either dropping the ball or this is
intentional I I at this point believe it
is intentional they want as many people
here as many people on the Dole as many
people voting illegally like I'm on
board all that stuff that that is just
my personal opinion come get me for it
but because this is happening uh Texas
is now saying enough is enough and we
are going to build a wall we are going
to pay private citizens so we can put a
wall on private property or they're
going to use eminent domain there's all
sorts of legal issues around all this
stuff but the point here is is something
that I've been trying to push for the
last few months which is that the
Republicans are not only getting balls
they are showing teeth
and balls that's
whoa the point is guys uh there is a new
attitude amongst conservatives at this
point which is we will not be messed
with relentlessly you cannot destroy the
known universe and watch us just sit
back and take it
foreign
[Music]